bonjour parce qu'on parle de choses
sérieuses mais qu'on se prend pas au
sérieux
et parce que le rire c'est bon pour la
santé on vous parle du festival de
l'humour
bienvenue sur 9,7 ktv bonjour mesdames
vraiment savez vous qu'on va parler du
premier spectacle alors vous votre
spectacle s'appelle casting quinqua d'où
sortent ce cas-là de l'artisanat le car
la force et la lettre de la force car il
a pris a pas longtemps on écrit casting
parce qu'il ya le cas et le s qui sont
en exerce comme 4 senna et stéphanie
sont recherchés ça c'est précieux et se
cherche bien d'hammamet époux thierry
henry a oui parce que thierry a écrit
mes enfants thierry jardinot oui mais
c'est un travail qui de plusieurs on
peut dire plusieurs mois par scanner
année d'y penser ça me rappelle c'est
vrai tu es chanteuse zazie je retenterai
pouvoir préparer pour voir c'est elle
qui s'occupe week-end à paris c'est vrai
ouais tu peux si tu veux en voix off
c'est peu dire que c'est là vraiment la
première scène de confidences d'accord
mais je peux venir leur tunis que tu
cries soir c'est vrai que ces retours on
s'est retrouvés sur scène il ya deux ans
la scène du super star tribune
on nous avait dit soyez les maîtresses
de ces mots de cérémonial à howard
américaine vous avez carte blanche et on
a improvisé des personnages on a joué
des chanteurs célèbres encore vivants ou
parfois des cds l'esprit d'amy winehouse
était venu sur scène et oui il y avait
eu connaissance
le public aussi à la fin les gagnants
naniwa nous donne comme ça alors aux
différents spectacles nous vient et il
fallait deux là oui voilà c'est de là
que stéphane hésitez pas à nous aussi
en fait ne longuement s'est appelée de
fruits soins la remote katiana il s'est
passé un truc de ouf
ouais ouais je n'arrête pas de nous et
on y va allons faire a offert peu de
vrai et c'est parti c'est parti comme ça
et diamants ont les mains liées à la
halle à l'occupation et comment ce wee
man et marié mener la même arrivée en
fin de match 2 ans sans vous marie aussi
à une famille recomposée plein jusque
composé comme salade face au genou va
l'amener là un petit garçon connaît là
c'est un petit icône et manu van est en
fait tu veux tout savoir m'a pas
toujours été photographe mandat comme
avec la clé
ma travail partout m'a fait at elle
compte y travaillent jusqu'au
vous travaillez même dans un atelier
mécanique ah ouais ouais jusqu'au jour
où mon chef d'atelier la passe à main de
la chose mais qu'on viol ça serait on
voit si la marque son nom kong où il a
reçu le ballon bleu de travail
la maman baisse de 6 ans il vit à la
fois la babouche violon ceci mais
jusqu'à aujourd'hui menacées quelles
sont au bush et dick 10 colis cause à la
non violence pourquoi nos maisons mais
c'est facile ou pas comme registre parce
que faire rire les gens c'est
particulier mais au moment où on se dit
qu'on se lance on sait que ça va pas
être facile on sait qu'on ne va devoir
travailler beaucoup c est autre chose
c'est pas pensé ou qu'on nous dit on
n'arrête pas de nous dire on vous attend
tonnant ça fait comme ça mais nous on
n'écoute pas trop ça tout ce qu'on sait
c'est qu'on doit on en a envie
on y met nos tripes et qu'à un moment
donné on a rencontré thierry jardinot
qui a validé le grain de folie
et voilà ça a commencé comme ça on
l'idée c'était de faire un spectacle
alors le festival de l'humour n'avait
rien à voir là dedans lui nous l'idée
c'était au départ il tacle avec nous
deux sur scène une comédie et d'ailleurs
c'est ce qu'on fait mais avec la patte
de thierry écriture de toutes les deux
qu'on vous dit thierry la cie thierry
basset c'est notre manière
pourquoi ça parce que l'inalco à
l'inalco de l'humour à la réunion le
code culturel et voilà forcément l'iran
dont le foie du foyer de mounir ont dans
la tête de mon niveau de la tête d'un
grand mère mon petit marmailles qui
cartonne lena une belle écriture une
belle profondeur de son écriture voilà
pourquoi tirer et dans la mise en scène
alliés sais pas d'où ça n'est pas bon là
n'est pas bon la laisser jouer l'aller
en dessous l'aller ce style aller cela
négligeable des spectateurs aussi et
c'est ça normalement parce que nous
c'est plutôt la comédie elle donc
et vécu mais moi dans d'autres séries en
tout cas on avait vraiment la sensation
de devoir relever un challenge qu'on
avait dans sa nounou même chaque fois et
c'est cet appel à moi oui
et effectivement c'était thierry aussi
parce que c'est un des leviers c'est la
relation avec l'image
pourquoi ça fait rire pourtant pour
approfondir ou pourquoi l'image rien
pourquoi les gens vont rire à cette
relation que vous avez avec l'image déjà
parce que c'est parce qu'il ya un
parallèle peut être un techno nos
métiers qui sont vie à l'image
willett et ça touche tout ça touche tout
le monde et aussi qu'on va pas le
reconnaître
justement va jouer là dessus oui on va
pas reconnaître qu'athènes à stéphanie
on va entrer en tout cas c'est ce qu'on
souhaitait me travaille pour ça dans les
personnages de ghislaine et jennyfer oui
on nouveau face et gommer complètement
et donc ça m'a fait rire tout simplement
parce que les gens seront pas accroché à
son image il ya des trucs qui recoupe un
peu mais dans le caractère parfois il
des libertés qu'on se permet oui coup de
gros créée voilà elle jure est miss jura
alors que dans l'industrie les jours
rien qu'au volant villégier et là bas la
bonne expression comme répondants ont
dit depuis super longtemps
il ya des situations d nous en scène des
phobies aussi message où seule une
phobie que beaucoup de monde ici là
réunionnais n'a et comment m y peut
réagir face à sa fin venir pour se
donner la liberté de rire et de voir
peut-être des personnes qui se donnent
la liberté d'être autre chose et qui
sont je vous ai pas posé c'est sûr
justement est ce que la femme peut faire
rire de tout faire rire de tout oui et
c'est la fin de tout est ce que oui bien
sûr bien sûr parce que nous ne peut pas
les autres que ne peut pas être de
l'accouchement il peut par les notes des
vergetures donc par là zot 2
en somme elle n'a pas préparé à moi oui
donnez pas si tu as ouvert tous devenir
des trucs les plus les plus horribles
mais avec avec beaucoup d'humour mais
sous la pluie aux libertés parce que
nous on a une sensibilité différente
sont ouais enfin nous les mieux quoi
c'est tout oui c'est ça cc voilà comme
la disputation sinon il est mieux ou
notre réponse c'est dur c'est bon en
tout cas plein de bonnes choses pour
cette première pour ce grand saut mais
vous avez vous avez réussi à transporter
le public
vous avez bien compris le message venez
venez dans les théâtres départementaux 1
c'est ça et un moment donné on s'occupe
de vous aussi un ouh là ça promet en
tout cas bientôt sur nos sept cas tv